at the start of the year jeff bezos
surprised wall street
by announcing that he was going to step
down from being amazon ceo
after the second quarter of 2021
according to bezos
the move wasn't about retiring or
cutting down responsibilities
but rather it was about focusing on
other passions and endeavors like blue
origin
bazel's plan was to become the executive
chairman of amazon
and let andy jassy become the new ceo
today
the second quarter just came to an end
and andy jassy just became the new
leader
of amazon but who even is andy jazzy
and how did he become bezos top choice
taking a look back
andrew jazzy was born on january 13 1968
in scarsdale new york andy's childhood
wasn't lavish or opulent per se
but he did have a well-off childhood as
his father everett jassy
was a senior partner at a law firm
called dewey valentine
this allowed andy to focus on his
education and eventually land a seat at
harvard
for his bachelor's andy would major in
government
which is quite not major maybe the plan
was to eventually attend law school and
join his father's company
i'm not quite sure but anyway andy would
score a job as a project manager
at a company called mbi inc after
graduation
during his time at mbi andy and one of
his colleagues would try to open a
business
as a side hustle but they soon came to
the realization that the business they
were building
was not something they wanted to do long
term so
they decided to shut it down soon after
andy would end up working at mbi for
five years
before returning to harvard to get an
mba after getting his mba
many of his colleagues from harvard and
andy would join amazon in 1997.
at the time amazon was only three years
old so they were able to score
management and direct roles
off the bat during his first couple of
years at amazon
andy took on a multitude of roles from
leading the customer relationship
management team
to serving as the director of marketing
but by far his most notable role was
being jeff bezos technical assistant in
the early 2000s
andy describes that being bezos
technical assistant was one of his most
valuable experiences
as it allowed him to learn how bezos ran
amazon
amazon however wasn't doing that well at
the time
fundamentally speaking the company was
still growing rapidly
as internet adoption skyrocketed but the
problem was that amazon was
not profitable combine this with the dot
com crash
and it's not hard to see why investors
dumped all of their amazon stock
driving the stock price down from 113
dollars to just
six dollars considering this rap return
in market sentiment
amazon decided to expand their business
plan and focus on profitability
this way they wouldn't be wiped out by
the next market crash
one of the original ideas to diversify
amazon was starting a service called
merchant.com this service would allow
third-party retailers to design their
own online websites
you see the main reason that amazon was
losing so much money
was because of the high cost of
fulfilling online orders
if they could shift the responsibility
of fulfilling orders to the sellers
amazon could quickly become profitable
but when they actually tried to develop
merchant.com
amazon ran into massive obstacles like
most startups
amazon's technical side wasn't the most
organized and this made it extremely
difficult for amazon to create a
powerful digital store development
platform
ironically shopify would do exactly this
six years later
and go to a valuation of a 182 billion
dollars
anyway realizing the technical
disorganization of the company
amazon would turn their focus onto
cleaning up this side of the business
but despite their efforts the company
saw no tangible results in terms of
development efficiency
at one point amazon was hiring dozens of
new software engineers
but this was not helping them build
merchant.com any faster
so andy would decide to look into the
problem and it didn't take long for him
to identify the culprit
the primary reason that new developments
took way longer than expected
was because of the massive amount of
time engineers were spending on setting
up databases
servers and other backend infrastructure
determined to solve this issue
amazon would set up a common
infrastructure service that the entire
company could use
this way engineers wouldn't have to set
up new infrastructure for every project
setting up this common infrastructure
did wonders for amazon as it finally
eliminated their technical issues
in the meantime amazon had also heavily
leaned up on the logistics side of their
business
this made amazon one of the most lean
and efficient businesses out there
but even with that amazon was still
losing money
due to how razor tender margins were so
jeff bezos would host an executive
meeting at his house
where they discussed the strengths and
weaknesses of the company all of them
knew that amazon was extremely efficient
at fulfilling orders
but what they didn't yet consider was
that amazon was also extremely efficient
when it came to backend infrastructure
according to andy the team never had an
aha moment to drastically change the
path of the company
but the team did identify the
possibility of selling infrastructure
services to other companies
they knew how hard it was to build up
efficient back-end infrastructure
so they thought they could provide
massive value to startups by allowing
them to rent amazon's already efficient
infrastructure
this service was just meant to be a side
household that padded amazon's losses
though
so amazon wasn't no rush to launch a
service and
they would just let it slowly
materialize in the background
eventually in 2006 amazon would launch
amazon web services or aws
which provided infrastructure as a
service andy jazzy was officially known
as the senior vice president of
amazon but he was basically the ceo of
aws
the reason they didn't originally give
him this title is because they didn't
expect aws to actually evolve into
basically
its own standalone company after all the
aws segment only had a total of 57
employees at the start
aws became profitable quite early on as
the service had pretty nice margins
but like the team anticipated aws was by
no means a game changer when it came out
demand for back-end infrastructure was
still rather low as
computer and especially smartphone
adoption were yet to take off
fortunately though aws did wonders for
amazon during the 2008 financial crisis
amazon stock would crash 83 at the end
of 2008 along with the broader market
but amazon would bounce back within a
year and they would never look back
after the recession andy jazzy would
turn aws focus
onto winning government contracts you
see the federal government had just
directed its agencies to transition from
data centers to the cloud
and this seemed like the preferred
market to leverage convincing government
agencies to actually use aws however
wasn't the easiest of tasks as you would
guess the government deals with highly
sensitive information
and they weren't sure how safe it was to
store this information on the service of
a private company
that were also used by hundreds of other
businesses one agency however
was ecstatic to switch over to aws and
this was nasa's jet proportion lab
the cto of the lab described the agency
knew that cloud computing was the future
eight years ago and that they were just
waiting for federal approval to make the
transition
so nasa would become one of aws's first
government customers
and one of their first projects with aws
was the curiosity rover
the images captured by the rover would
be hosted on aws
and available for public viewing
nonetheless other federal agencies still
weren't quite convinced however they
would outline a list of standards that
would allow companies to meet their
safety protocols
in 2013 amazon would become the first
company to meet these requirements
and aws would go on to win a 600 million
contract from the cia
in 2014. it didn't take long for aws to
dominate the government infrastructure
space
the government wasn't the only sector in
which aws dominated though
as smartphones exploded in popularity
during the early 2010s
we would see the rise of a plethora of
different startups who needed
infrastructure support
startups including airbnb stripe lyft
robinhood slack coinbase uber and many
many more
leverage aws after their first quarter
of 2015
amazon would release the financial
details about aws for the first time
aws had brought in 1.57 billion revenue
which was 50 higher than the first
quarter of 2014.
the best part though was that 265
million of that was
operating profit this was critical for
amazon
as the retail business was still only
breaking even at best
amazon would turn around and use a
profit from aws to invest into prime
vans
trucks planes and of course amazon prime
warehouses
in the meantime amazon separated aws
into more of a standalone company in
and andy jassy would become the ceo of
aws
as aws solidified their dominant
position amongst government agencies
and tech startups andy jassy started to
focus on flying much larger fish
winning over large companies however was
much more difficult
as they had the resources to build their
own backend infrastructure
andy knew that the key to convincing
large players to go with aws
instead of building their own was cost
efficiency fortunately
aws had economies of scale that
basically no one else could match
and this allowed them to be extremely
competitive when it came to price
between 2006 and 2018 aws reduced the
price of their services
67 times that's more than five price
cuts
every single year considering the
frequency of price cuts
it's not surprising that the cost of aws
services dropped 73
between 2014 and 2018. and as
andy hoped this was extremely effective
at winning over the big boys
today aws boasts customers including
pfizer
disney sony ge comcast bmw
and the biggest one samsung in may of
one analyst estimated that aws accounted
for 500 billion dollars worth of
amazon's 900 billion
market cap at the time given that aws
accounted for the vast majority of the
profit generated by amazon as a whole
it's not surprising that aws has been
amazon's most valuable asset
at the start of this year amazon's
retail business actually finally
overtook aws in terms of profit but
given amazon's 1.77 trillion
market cap aws is likely worth upwards
of one trillion dollars
nonetheless so at the end of the day who
is andy jazzy
well andy jazzy is the mastermind behind
aws
which is arguably the primary reason
that amazon was able to achieve
unbelievable economies of skill and grow
into the global ecommerce giant that
they are
today so it's really no wonder that andy
jazzy is the one succeeding jeff bezos
as a new ceo of amazon what do you guys
think about the story of andy jazzy
and aws comment that down below also
drop a like if you think andy jazzy was
the perfect choice
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then
i'm hari and i'll see you guys on the
next one